we're in the middle of a National
Emergency people are really scared and
families don't know if they can warm
their homes this winter and businesses
ask if they can keep the lights on that
is why the labor party spent the summer
fighting for a price freeze so that no
household would pay a penny more on
their bills
when we call for it many people said we
were wrong they pretended that this
crisis was something that just affected
the poorest as if Working Families on
average wages could easily shoulder
astronomical bills they dismissed our
call for support as handouts
but those objections could never last
the Primus had no choice no government
can stand by while millions of families
fall into poverty whilst businesses shut
their doors and the economy Falls to
ruin so I am pleased there is action
today and that the principle and that
the principle of a price limit has been
accepted but under our plan not a penny
more on bills under this plan a price
rise
but this support I'll just make some
progress and then I will but this
support does not come cheap and the real
question before the house today the real
question the government faces the
political question is who is going to
pay
the treasury estimates that energy
producers could make
170 billion pounds in unexpected
windfall profits over the next two years
I repeat that
170 billion pounds in unexpected
windfall profits over the next two years
I will give way in just a moment the
head of BP has called this crisis a cash
machine for his company and households
are on the other end of that cash
machine their bills funding these
eye-watering profits that's why we've
been calling for a windfall tax since
January and it's why we want to see the
windfall tax expanded now
prime minister
is opposed to windfall taxes
she wants to leave these vast profits on
the table with one clear and obvious
Consequence the bill will be picked up
by working people
[Applause]
she claims she claims that a windfall
tax will deter investment
that's ridiculous
these vast promets these vast price
prophets are not the reward of careful
planning they are the unexpected
windfall from Putin's barbarity in
Ukraine there's no reason why taxing
them would affect investment in the
future
[Applause]
don't just take my word for it asked
which investment BP would cancel if
there was a windfall tax the chief
executive said
none
none his words not mine so the prime
minister's only argument against the
windfall tax falls apart at first
inspection
laying bare that she's simply driven by
dogma and it's working people that will
pay for that Dogma
I will give away
does he accept
government has already introduced a
windfall tax and energy companies today
are paying six oh it paid 65 percent on
their on their profits what would he
rather see that tax set up
what's up we're talking about what
happens this winter and next
um and I think doesn't
it doesn't understand
every every pound every pound the
premises government refuses to raise in
Windfall taxes which is leaving billions
on the table is an extra pound of
borrowing that's the simple
straightforward argument every pound she
leaves on the table is an extra pound of
borrowing loading the burden of the cost
of in crisis onto working people who
will have to pay back for years to come
I will I'm grateful to my right
honorable friend the Prime Minister has
been careful to frame her guarantee in
terms of her refusal to tax
but is she not going to have a problem
explaining to the British people how a
levy on their bills in the future to
repay the borrowing is not actually a
tax
[Applause]
I'm grateful for that intervention this
is the basic political divide
they want to protect the excess profits
of the Oil and Gas and energy the access
Province we want to protect working
people